you probably know that all stuff is made
up of atoms and that an atom is a really
really really really tiny particle every
atom has a core which is made up of at
least one positively charged particle
called a proton and in most cases some
number of neutral particles called
neutrons that core is surrounded by
negatively charged particles called
electrons the identity of an atom is
determined only by the number of protons
in its nucleus hydrogen is hydrogen
because it has just one proton carbon is
carbon because it has six Gold is gold
because it has 79 and so on indulge me a
momentary tangent how do we know about
atomic structure we can't see protons
neutrons or electrons so we do a bunch
of experiments and develop a model for
what we think is there then we do some
more experiments and see if they agree
with the model if they do great if they
don't it might be time for a new model
we've had lots of very different models
for atoms since Democritus in 400 BC and
there will almost certainly be many more
to come
ok tangent over the cores of atoms tend
to stick together
but electrons are free to move and this
is why chemists love electrons if we
could marry them we probably would but
electrons are weird they appear to
behave either as particles like little
baseballs or as waves like water waves
depending on the experiment that we
perform one of the weirdest things about
electrons is that we can't exactly say
where they are it's not that we don't
have the equipment it's that this
uncertainty is part of our model of the
electron so we can't pinpoint them fine
but we can say there's a certain
probability of finding an electron in a
given space around the nucleus and that
means that we can ask the following
question if we drew a shape around the
nucleus such that we would be 95% sure
of finding a given electron within that
shape what would it look like
here are a few of these shapes chemists
call them orbitals and what each one
looks like depends on among other things
how much energy it has the more energy
an orbital has the farther most of its
density is from the nucleus by the way
why did we pick 95% and not a hundred
percent well that's another quirk of our
model of the electron past a certain
distance from the nucleus the
probability of finding an electron
starts to decrease more or less
exponentially which means that while it
will approach zero it will never
actually hit zero so in every atom there
is some small but nonzero probability
that for a very very short period of
time
one of its electrons is at the other end
of the known universe but mostly
electrons stay close to their nucleus as
clouds of negative charge density that
shift and move with time how electrons
from one atom interact with electrons
from another determines almost
everything atoms can give up their
electrons surrendering them to other
atoms where they can share electrons and
the dynamics of this social network are
what make chemistry interesting from
plain old rocks to the beautiful
complexity of life the nature of
everything we see hear smell taste touch
and even feel is determined at the
atomic level
you